and news that i think a lot of us would
consider to be quite predictable
starfield has been
delayed and there are a couple of things
that i want to talk about here that i
don't doubt i've spoken about on the
channel before
same common misconceptions keep coming
up so let's dive into it um first the
news itself this is from bethesda
on
the twitter and it says an update on red
fall which of course is arcane's game
and starfield they posted a text uh
image thing at least they have alt text
a lot of them don't do that
um
which you should take to mean every
single time is the game delay just every
single time at this point anytime a game
studio has to post an image the game is
being delayed
it says
we've made the decision to delay the
launches of red fall and starfield to
the first half of 2023.
the teams at arcane austin redfall and
bethesda game studios star field have
incredible ambitions for their games and
we want to ensure that you receive the
best most polished versions of them we
want to thank everyone for their
excitement for redfull and starfield
that energy is a huge part of what
inspires all of us every day and drives
our own excitement for what we are
creating and we can't wait to share our
first deep dive into the gameplay for
both red fall and starfield soon
which i think is ultimately
why
the delay hasn't surprised many people
is that we've not really seen anything
okay this is from ign.com
it's funny that advertising keeps to me
my search history probably does make me
seem like a middle-aged man anyway
starfold and redfield delayed to 2023.
that's good-looking honey
um bethesda has announced blah blah can
we do all this oh yes this is a pot that
i wanted to mention um
we expect the we can't wait to share our
first deep dive into the gameplay for
both red fall and starfield soon i would
think that that uh is a reference to the
xbox but there's the summer showcase
june 12th though they haven't confirmed
that um but i'd be very surprised if
that's not what they were referring to
so there is a follow-up from the
bethesda studios account that says we
can't wait for you to play starfield but
we need some more time we're so thankful
for all the sport encouragement and are
excited to show you the game soon which
i can only imagine has positive replies
oh just
just a lot of uh console fanboy
responses there
yep nice
um arcane followed up with a tweet
with a message from medford's director
harvey smith here at arcane austin we've
decided to delay the launch of red falls
smith explain the team needs more time
to bring the game to life thank you so
much for your continued support red fall
is our most ambitious game yet which
again i'm very surprised by and we can't
wait to show it off soon starfield
previously had a release date of
november 11 uh which is an important
date for bethesda given skyrim was
released on the same date in 2011. the
xbox console exclusive has been showing
off a number of details recently from
the game's companions to its factions to
its music but we've never actually seen
gameplay again the reason that i didn't
think it would come out though
the way that they dropped
fallout 4
i believe i was in the audience for that
uh e3 conference
was they had teased it we all kind of
knew it was coming
they showed gameplay and then it was out
within 12 months god that was good and i
feel like bethesda did that for their
first two conferences
ah the dream um but it's so much harder
than that it's a lot more complicated
than that
red fall has been even quieter announced
as xbox's show closer during e3 last
year the new game from arcane austin was
introduced as an open world co-op fps
due for release this summer i suppose
any open world game is very hard to make
however since that reveal we see nothing
of the game aside from some leaked
images the lack of gameplay for both
games had been seen by some as simply
holding back for a major drop during
summer but it seems reality is that both
games simply aren't ready for release
just yet so
totally they can hold gameplay back that
is definitely a thing it is a strategy
um that a lot of studios have
sony specifically i know um
tends to like that strategy they call it
um or at least i've been seeing it been
referred to as
bombs not bullets which is like dropping
these big events and not little tiny
bits of marketing which i tend to prefer
um but
it's very different when you're making a
game that in theory should be the size
of star fields you you gotta market that
for a while so people have an
understanding of how much they can do in
a big open world because that's what
people are expecting so i'm not at all
surprised by the delay i don't think
many people are again a little bit more
surprised by red fall
um
but either way it's fine so a couple of
things that i wanted to talk about when
i first covered this news i do news on
tick tock for video games and i first
made a tick tock video about it before
making this video
there are so many responses
along the lines of
why don't they just wait to announce
release dates until they're sure and i
don't think people realize how
complicated this is um so the first and
the most simple thing
actually let me even back myself up the
first and most important thing is delays
are good you want games to be delayed if
you
are in the camp of people who complains
about game delays but then also
complains about buggy releases you are
part of the problem if you're one of the
people who on every post
that a studio makes are saying where's
the release date when's the game coming
out [ __ ] you release date please and
there are a lot of those
are part of the problem um i think we
just like need to get rid of this hype
we have on release dates and i certainly
think that people being wrong about
release dates or studios being wrong
about release dates sucks but no one is
actually hurt by it um i feel like at
this point
safe bet to just assume all release
dates are tentative and are like
approximate or um
hopeful attempts and that aren't
necessarily real uh but
like i see some people are like this is
ridiculous i'm being disrespected i
think that's absurd
you're not you should want the game to
be delayed so that you can get a better
game they don't delay it for fun
they're not delaying it because of elder
rings or some people say that that is
absolutely not how game studios work
there's just no universe in which that
happens the only time that that will
happen is if uh
a publisher themselves has a delay so
say like a ubisoft
assassin's creed gets delayed
they will want to delay another game
that they're working on at the same time
so that their own portfolio doesn't
release too close together
that definitely happens you'll see
publishers will delay games if their own
games have been delayed so that they
have releases sort of more evenly spaced
out that has happened in aaa a number of
times um i don't think anyone ever says
that
but that is definitely a thing that
happens which is internal delays because
of other internal delays um
as for other games coming out
no that's not a thing that that happens
and yeah a lot of people saying what
devs need to stop doing this it's not
the dev teams who are doing this i don't
think any dev would like to have a
release date um
ahead of time other than to know when
they get to stop working so
that's the most interested i think an
individual developer would be is to know
when they get a break from the tireless
work that goes into making a video game
um and how much longer they have to put
in all that hard work for
to try to manage their lives and plan
for their families etc but the devs are
not the ones who announce release dates
that is marketing teams and it's not a
lack of communication
when this is wrong um and this isn't
correct 100 of time either sometimes it
is the deaf teams but majority of the
time safe to assume in this case uh it
is not that the teams aren't talking and
are getting things wrong but sometimes
marketing is beholden to things that
don't actually pertain to game
development like stockholders like
shareholders like the market um
sometimes you need to have a portfolio
of this coming out in this quarter and
this coming out in this quarter not
actually for the public not actually for
gamers to prepare for
you're gonna get their money anyway they
know that um it is so that the
shareholders
can see what the projections for profits
in certain quarters are and that's a
bigger part of it than i think a lot of
gamers realize is that it's not actually
about you
it's about stock market in a lot of
cases
uh but yes it's not the dev teams doing
it please stop saying devs have to stop
lying the second thing is people like
they shouldn't announce until they're
ready just wait until you're ready it's
so hard to mark it that way it's very
very very very difficult to project when
a triple a game will actually be
finished virtually impossible and i
don't think that's a fixable problem
unless
the way that project management is
currently structured completely changes
even then
i think
gamers are better off having a little
flexibility like say that the games in
the future
and this is some of the stuff i've been
seeing people say this morning say games
in the future are beholden to release
dates no matter what say some law passes
that says if you say this is the release
date this is the day that you have to
come out you're going to get way worse
quality games that you do not want that
it is not a thing that you want you you
need to be able to to let them make
games better because that's that's what
they're trying to do is just make sure
you have a better experience uh
yeah i saw someone say it was something
like we need to hold them accountable
for the dates that they say it's like no
they you don't you don't want them to be
accountable for the dates you want them
to be accountable for quality video
games they're two different things um
but they're very very very hard to
predict and that's because they're so
much bigger than almost every other
entertainment medium they're just
so big so many people doing so many
things things are constantly shifting
making a triple-a game is just very very
very hard making an indie game is hard
making any game is hard and i know
people say that all the time
and people like yeah i get it my job's
all so hard but
when i tell you it's impossible
to 100 accurately predict a date
they made it it can't be done it's just
so many moving parts
and unique video games is that the
moving parts break all the other parts
like one part moves and then 10 parts
break that doesn't tend to happen when
you're making a movie or an album right
it's very specific to video games and
certainly very unfortunate um
and if you were to wait until the game
is gold before you start even marketing
it or before you uh announce a release
date your marketing cycle is very
difficult like you could project
internally that it's a lot sooner so the
marketing team goes okay it's probably
going to come out in 2020 let's start
marketing in 2018 so people know what it
is and know it's on their horizon and
then it gets delayed till 2025 and then
you have everybody burnt out on the
marketing with something that they no
longer care about because they've seen
it marketed for too long um
and it's just it's just complicated it's
just complicated none of this stuff is
as simple as i think
a lot of the conversation tends to
suggest which is why don't they just
wait
and why don't they stick to release
dates uh neither of those things is
an easy option and of course
i would prefer that i would certainly
prefer things waited a little bit
um and we got accurate release dates
that that's great i just don't see it
actually being possible
and i don't think it's malicious
um it's just kind of the way a large
very profitable industry works so
stuff are being delayed not a surprise
the thing i appreciate is the um
candid nature of how much advance
they're giving people information like
this game wasn't close it's not like it
was coming out next week it was the end
of the year it's not even june yet nick
told us it's now 2023 so hopefully
that's correct
one very funny comment that i also saw
this morning was somebody said everyone
needs to take a page out of rockstar's
book
they've delayed like every single game
they delay games
all the time everyone does because it's
so hard not to
make video games is hot
and
i think people have said this before i
think it might even be like a miyamoto
quote i don't remember
games never done a game has just shipped
you could always work on it for longer
and improve things and make things
better but then it would just never come
out i'll a star citizen
you need
the game to come out eventually and you
do have to make cuts and you do have to
allow certain bugs to get in you do have
to work on patches to be able to even
release a game because they are never
ending projects if you allow them to be
they will just never end especially
because the technology gets better bit
by bit right so as you're working on
something for five years
the technology is improving underneath
you and you can't just
shift everything over to whatever
upgrade is now possible on the engine
that you're using uh we have seen some
games delay recently because they
switched from
unreal florida unreal 5
um which is like a choice that you've
made like you could have brought it out
on 4 but the technology got so much
better because unreal 5 looks [ __ ]
awesome and so it's been delayed to
accommodate that
i think that's pretty much it you just
wanted to like
candidly chat about some of the comments
that i've seen delays are always good
you should be supportive of delays you
should always want delays stop asking
for release dates
just in general people are very
aggressive and demanding about them
trust me go read any of the comments
under virtually any sony santa monica
studio post and you'll see
the the vitro with which people
are demanding a release date for god of
war ragnarok it is it is intense but
then at the same time if they got one
and it got delayed they'd be upset
i
resign myself to the idea of the
industry working how it works which is
release dates are approximate
you got to stop taking them seriously
and i'm aware that that seems ridiculous
because if you say something's coming
out it should come out on that date
but the reality is just so much more
complicated than that and doesn't
necessarily actually pertain to gamers
in a lot of cases sometimes it's like
the requirements of the marketing team
the requirements of the stock market
whatever else it's just
whole thing is complicated delays are
good we are okay with them we appreciate
being told well ahead of time